hey guys Seb here rockstar has dated GTA
5 for pc ps4 and xbox one we've got all
the details you need to know right here
in this GS news update nothing but
make-believe will ever feel quite real
again grand theft auto 5 will be coming
to playstation 4 and xbox one consoles
on November eighteenth just two months
from now PC uses however will have to
wait over two months more to get their
hands on the upgraded game releasing on
january 27 2015 the new release will see
major upgrades over the current version
available on xbox 360 and playstation 3
including enhanced detail and longer
draw distances new weapons vehicles and
activities additional wildlife denser
traffic new foliage system enhanced
damage and weather effects plus over a
hundred additional new songs and mixes
from returning djs on the in-game radio
and up to 30 player GTA online sessions
for ps4 and xbox one pre-ordering will
net you 1,000,000 in-game bucks split
50-50 across the single and multiplayer
modes for owners of the ps3 and 360
versions there will also be some
exclusive content landing classic GTA
vehicles like the Dukes the dodo
seaplane and a faster more maneuverable
blimp plus new activities challenges and
weapons but if you fancy making the
switch to one of the newer platforms you
will be able to transfer your character
and progress from your current system
will you be picking up a copy of GTA 5
for your ps4 or xbox one or
alternatively are you going to wait all
the way into next year for the pc
version let me know in the comments and
for all the latest info on GTA 5 stay
tuned to gamespot
you